so what I want to do today since this is
a conference on
proneural I thought I would give a
little bit of a background on kind of
the story of how Khan Academy started I
think some of y'all might be a
reasonably familiar actually before I
even start how many of y'all have been
to the side or watched a Khan Academy
video or oh very good I think we have a
very high penetration in our demographic
that's our so all our you and I think
it'll be interesting because I think
that the story of Khan Academy more than
almost most entrepreneurial stories is
kind of a I don't want to say accidental
I want to think that some of it was
somewhat by design but but it has been
this kind of organic process and it's
still not 100 percent clear where all of
this is going to lead to although it
seemed like it could to lead it could
lead to something pretty exciting so we
can rewind back to 2004 and I was an
analyst at a hedge fund in Boston and my
my aunt and uncle and their children my
cousins were visiting me from New
Orleans right after my wedding I got
married in New Jersey with back to
Boston and they were visiting me in my
and the oldest of their children Nadia
she was 12 years old and they it was
fourth of July weekend in Boston I know
if y'all and y'all been to Boston they
have a nice poor kind of 4th of July
fireworks thing over the Charles River
and I distinctly remember while we were
waiting for the fireworks to start we I
was just killing time by giving my
family brain teasers the kind of brain
teasers you know that a good interview
question at Google or you know whatever
and and I don't know if y'all ever done
this with your family but some people
say oh I don't care like I don't want to
think right now and all the rest but I
just Inc Lee remember Nadia being one if
she's 12 years old she's like we don't
tell me the answer I can figure it out
you know can they see each other you
know what others say she was truck at 12
years old she was tackling these brain
teasers as well as I you know any any 25
year old computer science grad that had
ever had ever interviewed before so so I
remember the next day we were we were
touring the colleges and and we went to
MIT and I remember telling Nadia I was
like you should you know I'm pretty
impressed by how well you tackled a lot
of those brain teasers yesterday you
should you should think about you should
think about MIT and I remember right
when I said that my aunt gave a little
look to my uncle and and I wasn't sure
what that look was about maybe it was
something else we got
related but but uh yeah but I remember
that look and and the very next morning
my ought never thought she told me you
know the South thank you so much for
believing in navi it really means a lot
you're like a big brother to to my
children and a role model but I thought
I would let you know that Nadia's
actually having trouble in math that
she's gotten great grades she's a
straight-a student but she just took a
placement exam and she did not place
into the the kind of a standard track
where you would take algebra in 8th
grade and so on and so forth
she got placed into a slower track and
so I said that that's impossible you
know that she was tackling stuff way
more abstract and deep and
thought-provoking two nights ago then I
could then anything that you could
imagine covered in a sixth or seventh
grade math class so when Nadia woke up I
said hey Nadia I have trouble believing
this what do you what did you not
understand why do you think you didn't
do well in the placement exam and I said
it was units
you know converting kilograms to grams
and all of the rest and I said Nadia I'm
100% you can you can tackle that so what
do you say when you go back to New
Orleans and I stay in Boston after my
work and after your school I tutor you
we do something over speakerphone we'll
figure out a way to be able to see what
each other what what we're riding and
all that and we ended up using Yahoo
doodle and we started doing this and it
was kind of fun for me I mean you know
even while I was at the hedge fund I
always have this you know when anyone
works at a hedge fund you kind of have a
rationale for why you're doing it
although I do I do have an argument of
how it actually does contribute to
society but that would take me longer
than this talk the but but I used to
tell my friends I want to do this job
long enough so that I could save enough
money that I could start a school on my
own terms that was always something that
was a little bit in the back of my mind
I didn't really have a sense of what
that would mean but it was kind of like
this life ambition for me and so it was
fun for me to tutor my cousin because it
was like hey I can start to warm up I
can start to and help my cousin's in the
process and the first month was
difficult I remember with Nadia it was
like you know X plus 3 is equal to 10
what is X and you know her answers were
all
like seven or I'd say if you have two
kilometers how many meters and she would
should say two thousand and I was like
are you sure and and it was it was this
thing that she was a smart girl but she
had just had no confidence she she
anything outside of math her brain was
engaged as soon as she got kind of a
formal math problem it's like she didn't
want to think and so there's a couple of
things that I had done early on it that
I don't talk a lot about this because
the videos are what Khan Academy is most
gotten most known for is very early on
as like I want to make something for
Nadia so that I can make sure she has
100% proficiency of the core stuff so
that she doesn't answer every question
with with another question
so so I wrote this little thing this
little you know JavaScript question
generator for her then literally give
her as many units problems as necessary
until she should get ten in a row or as
many you know basic algebra exponents or
whatever any of these core skills and
then you know every every the next day
on our tutoring session I'd say well did
you do the problems and and she said oh
yeah I did I mean I didn't really
believe her so I put a database behind
it to so I could keep track of when she
did the problems how many how much time
was it taking her and all the rest very
simple stuff at this point and then I
started making one module after another
I mean this was literally like a
dedicated software effort for one 12
year old at the time but but she
eventually did progress through the the
tutoring and the software which had no
you know the videos aren't even on the
radar at this point then I started to to
her younger brothers more and more
family members it was kind of this this
fun thing I mean sometimes when I'd call
up a distant relative I was like can I
tutor your kids they thought that there
was some type of strange catch to it but
uh they're they're like Sal must not be
doing well on this hedge-fund thing he's
he's uh it's but but you fast forward
now to 2006 I had this like cohort of
like twenty or thirty kids around the
country that different time zones I
still had a day job and I would come
home and I try to tutor them all and and
and do these sessions I would try to do
these conference calls with more than
one student that got that got tricky and
I would vent it at a dinner party and
and one of my buddies Uli says you know
why don't you just why don't you just
record some of your lecture
on YouTube and I said no not YouTube
that's for dogs on skateboards that's
that's not for serious mathematics but
but then you know I kind of went home
and once I got over the idea that it
wasn't my idea I I decided I decided to
give it a shot and I I put those first
YouTube videos up there I think it was
greatest common devisor or at least
common multiple and I started doing a
bunch of them 20 or 30 the same stuff
that I was covering with my cousin's at
the time and and a couple of things
happened and you know I joke about this
a lot but it's absolutely true the first
feedback I got from my cousin's was they
they liked me better on YouTube than in
person and and I'm hoping it's only in a
kind of an education tutorial context
but it actually makes a lot of sense
they could pause they could repeat
there's a lot to be said about human
interaction there's a lot to be said
about kind of human mentorship and I
think they value that they value the
fact that their cousin who was in Boston
who had a job who was married took the
time out of his day to care about their
lives they definitely that definitely
was was a positive for them but I could
tell just from my interactions that the
actual tutoring session was super
stressful but you know no one wants to
say that they don't understand no one
wants to their their cousin to feel like
oh maybe you know Nadia isn't worth the
time or maybe out she's wasting my time
and so all of a sudden they could do it
in a distressed environment and then
when we had our live sessions it was
just really for really four questions
the other thing that happened is I
started getting letters from people I
just randomly put it on YouTube you know
I remember that first time YouTube says
do you want to make these private or
public and I was like I don't care
public and and other people's started to
watch it first I was suspicious cuz you
know I told four cousins to watch the
video and like six people would watch it
I was like who are these two people that
are watching my videos and I never saw
Julia and Julia where she wrote a blog
and she keeps refreshing it to see if
people are watching that was me in 2006
and but then all of a sudden it became
clear that definitely people who I
weren't who I wasn't related to were
watching the videos and then they
started to comment they started to say
thank you or wish that by itself is huge
because I know if you've seen most of
the comments on YouTube
they're not they're not all g-rated so
so and frankly I think even if I was a
physical teacher just to get a thank you
from a student every now and then that's
a pretty powerful idea and so I would
start getting these thank-yous but then
the comments would be like I was gonna
flunk algebra and I'm the top student in
algebra because I watched those four
videos and I was like my god
I was sleeping or taking a nap or
shaving or something and and this person
was able to learn algebra that's a
pretty profound idea and so you can
imagine I just got excited and I just I
just kept going when I started off I I
didn't think this was you know there's
something in my head that says this is a
neat idea I can make that video on least
common multiple once and it's there
forever and my cousin's can use it and
even if no one else uses it it's kind of
a nice little thing for the family maybe
my grandkids could eventually use it or
my great-great grandkids it'd kind of be
like this neat thing and maybe maybe in
the future other people might might
actually want it so I just kept going
and and I try was building out the
software at the same time until you you
fast forward to any end the softer it's
funny because I made all of these
modules and then I could add a lot of
this has come out of being lazy III I I
got tired of assigning the modules to my
cousin's I was like because before I was
like okay not the anigh that you got ten
in a row on this you're now ready for
this module now that you've gotten ten
in a row and negative numbers you're not
ready for fractions and that got tiring
for me so I set them up in this kind of
graph structure and so it would
automatically assign them once you got
ten in a row and this you're not ready
for these models once you get turned
around those she's not ready for those
modules and I said well yeah this is
kind of a neat graph structure I had it
visually displayed for myself so I could
keep track of all these modules said let
me let me have my cousin's look at them
and so they once again they like that
but they could see where they were going
and what they needed to do to understand
to eventually get to trigonometry or
eventually get to geometry or whatever
so I had that out there and this is
another probably thing not to do if
you're trying to and I wasn't trying to
start a business or not-for-profit at
this point but that software loan got so
popular by 2007 that it was taking down
my $50 a month web hosting and you know
my brilliant entrepreneurial mind said
oh then I'll just turn it off and see
instead of being a hundred dollars a
month
so that happened
the video traffic kept growing a
hundreds thousands ten thousands until
you fast forward to 2008 and then some
some interesting even across some
interesting things started to happen
I'll show you getting letters from
teachers because once I got this is just
from my cousin's you know whatever but
teacher starts saying you already gave
the lecture on on on adding fractions I
don't have to give the lecture anymore
so now I'm assigning these for my
students and then I use my lecture my
class time the teachers class time to
actually interact with my students to
actually kind of flip the classroom so
now that students can do homework and
while they're in the room and and and
and and get the lecture at home at their
own pace and get all the benefits that
my cousin's had you know the reason why
they liked them to begin with and so you
fast forward to 2009 and this whole
thing just got kind of too exciting and
I had trouble focused on focusing on
generating alpha and my day job and and
so and you know this is probably the
fourth iteration where I kind of was
tempted to quit my job you know the
previous three we kind of looked at our
finances and says no we can't but but by
the fourth we're like you know it
wouldn't be completely ridiculous to try
this out for a year and my rationale was
at this point I was like there is
something here because I you know at
this point I was getting hundreds of
letters a day and these were not letters
of someone saying oh this was nice to
have this help me review for an exam
some of these letters were like this is
the reason why I could go to college or
this is the only reason why I'm able to
pass class X Y or Z it sounds like
there's something here made the decision
to make it a not-for-profit just because
really I wanted many as many people as
possible to use it and and so I was
thinking you know there's so much worry
about education right now let me just
keep doing it and I took the most naive
approach to starting a not-for-profit or
really starting a business i I just kept
making videos and hoping someone would
notice and so 2009 I did that you fast
forward luckily by May June July August
of 2009 people people began to notice
Google brought me in they said you know
a lot of our engineers a lot of our
people here they like to use your videos
with their kids would you be willing to
talk to us so I go to Google and you
know like halfway into the beating like
so so what would you do if if
with two million dollars and I said you
know is this an education context are
just a broader question for what I would
do with very different answers there but
it was clear was about education and so
I said you know I would well beyond
giving myself a salary I would I would I
would build out that software platform
that I started off for my cousin's so
that students can all work at their own
pace so that teachers can get data and
analytics and what the students are up
to so that we could take this model that
these teachers had already started
experimenting with this model of
flipping the classroom and and and kind
of supercharging it with the software so
if you have that if you have the
software now whether you're at home or
you're at school every kid could work at
their own pace in the same classroom you
could have kids doing 5th grade math and
kids doing trigonometry and and the
teachers role will now not be grade
papers not to be lecturer but to spend
every moment of their time interacting
with students having and having the
students every moment of their time not
sitting passively in a room waiting you
know waiting for the period to end but
to actually interact with each other and
maybe tutor each other and so they like
the idea so it looked like that that
funding process was happening although
it you know it didn't that didn't happen
until later on and this is a lesson I
learned and you know I only have one
experience in this but it's like one of
these things where there's a period of
time where you think boy
someone needs to notice this and you
think you're doing something that's
pretty cool and that you're your
customers or your students or whatever
it's like this is a life-changing thing
and you're doing it but no one else is
noticing and at some point like nine
months into it I was getting pretty
insecure I was getting like you know I
need to start updating my resume I don't
know if the hedge fund world will hire
me back because I've done this flaky
thing and all of this all all of this
stuff but then once all of a sudden it
did hit it was kind of kind of crazy
because it was literally in the same you
know Google looked like that process was
going
anin John Doerr actually they were the
first to to give to say you you at
minimum deserve a salary and then in
August of 2010 so this is very recent
this is like last year I get I think was
July or August I get a I get a
from an she was to the Aspen Institute
saying Bill Gates is in front of 2,000
people talking about you right now and I
said that prankster and she or or maybe
that that text was sent to the wrong
person because it was a very surreal
idea but later on about two weeks later
I got a call from from mr. Gates's
office saying you may or may not know
but but Bill's a fan he uses these
videos himself and he uses them with his
kids and I mean when they said this like
I better review some of those videos and
see what I oh well what I've said but uh
but he said any he would like to meet if
you have some time and I was literally
staring at a blank calendar and and uh
and I was like oh yeah I think I can
move a few things around and you know we
we should be able to figure out
something and and so uh we met and he
asked how he could support I was like
well you know it would be nice to come
out of the closet so to speak and and
and so he I was recording in the closet
that's the see and and so he supported
us we got office space we have a team
and then Google came in and now we are
essentially a team or eight people now
we're based in downtown Mountain View
and we're building out this software
platform and videos I keep making videos
to kind of provide an education for
anyone anywhere and we've started a
pilot in Los Altos one once again we
didn't think our strategy was you know
go into classrooms right from the get-go
we were focused on on the end student
you know the the millions of students
are out there right now we have two
million students using it on their own
every month but Los Altos came to us and
said what you do in a classroom if you
had cart blush and we said look we're
building this thing every kid work at
their own pace we didn't think they
would be into it but the next day they
said yep can we start in two weeks and
and so we have two fifth grade classes
two seventh grade classes in Los Altos
now and it's been pretty tremendous I
think all of the indicators we could
talk maybe more about that later have
been very positive you know and just to
give a little bit of a clue of kind of
the power of this is very recently a
reporter came to one of the classrooms
to just do a story on us and she saw a
fifth grader in one of those classrooms
doing trigonometry just sitting there
doing trigonometry problems you know
very casually
and the reporters very impressed and so
she sits down next to the fifth grader
and says so so do you think that this is
do you think this is fifth-grade math
and then and then then the little girl
has this very mischievous look on her
face and she goes no I think it's sixth
grade okay so and so now going forward I
think our strategy is two things and our
strategy frankly changes every week but
but the strategies to things is build
out our software platform we're actually
translating it to ten languages so it
can reach more than just the English
speakers of the world build out the
software platform so right now the
exercises go deep they go into it you
saw on the video they go into vector
calculus and biology and college
chemistry and history and all the rest
but have the exercise platform first go
through K through calculus and then
beyond that college-level math and
chemistry biology physics all the rest
and build out what we're doing in these
schools so over the next over the next
year we're going to go to about 10 to 15
schools and school districts to kind of
expand this Los Altos idea and see how
we can really transform what what
happens in the classroom so that's kind
of an update on what we're up to and I
think now we can we can I believe
there's this going to be a Q&A part of
this okay
for those of you living in the Bay Area
the person who's going to have a
Chatwood salad needs no introduction
three-time Emmy Award winning Raj Mathai
who just three months ago was named news
anchor for MBC Bay Area and he was very
well-regarded sportscaster for a number
of years with that station so let me
welcome to the stage Raj Mathai hello
everyone what we're doing so first of
all is he a stand-up comedian or an
educator this is phenomenal yeah that
was wonderful
no but by virtue of my name I feel the
desire to entertain bus but all right
but I will keep my shirt on that's my
only that's it
I'm glad you brought it up because the
first thing this morning I'm putting out
my suit getting ready to come here and
my wife says you know what's happening
today said I'm going to the the Thai
convent and we're gonna spend part of
the afternoon with Salman Khan and she
dropped to the race to the closet what
am I gonna wear you're coming with me I
said no the real salamanca everything
about more of an impact I think than the
other one right now if you want if you
want to really if you want to if you
want a really surreal story so
apparently Bill Gates did a search for
Salman Khan and he forwarded his entire
organization the other guy saying did
you know there's another Salman Khan and
just the idea of seeing Bill Gates look
at Salman Khan without his shirt on it
was a very dissonant anyway not about
him but yeah yeah well I think like so
many people like everyone here in the
audience I - just backstage just
captivated about your story and this
isn't the first time that I've heard
about your story I've been following you
for a while now so so what happens now
you here we are we have a lot of
entrepreneurs we have a lot of venture
capitalists and one of the big questions
is okay this is great it's it seems very
successful but it's not for profits so
at what point
what is it for then what point do you
turn the corner if that if that point is
even on your radar yeah no we're
definitely not gonna turn that you know
this isn't like a bait and switch we're
not gonna you know be not-for-profit at
some point you know I think I would have
to do something pretty Shady at this
point to actually turn it into a
for-profit no so you know the simple
answer is no we're gonna stay a
not-for-profit the decision early on was
and I think a lot of y'all can and I'm
not saying that there's anything wrong
with for-profit I obviously worked in a
very for-profit industry before this
pretty much that's all it was for that
that's the next session at 2 o'clock
yeah stock tips from no but but you know
early on even it was in 2008 actually
some VCS that approached me and and it
was it was actually pretty exciting
conversation number one because they
said hey you know this is awesome we can
fund this you'll be able to get a salary
you can keep doing these videos
full-time you don't have to find all the
spare time to do it and you know we can
we can do you know it'll be a double
bottom line business or we could have
social venture or whatever you want to
call it and and you know if it works out
you'll be rich and that didn't sound bad
to me so we scheduled another meeting
and but but it was obvious by meeting
too that there was just something that
wasn't I'm not saying this is there's
anything wrong with this but I was just
enjoying this so much I mean it was
really kind of like why I woke up in the
morning and by meeting - the
conversation started to become like well
you know you should continue doing this
but we should focus more on test prep
and maybe we could charge for this or
have a subscription model or freemium or
whatever you want to call it and you
know I'm not saying that they were wrong
or bad or but I just started it didn't
feel as fun all of a sudden and so I was
just like you know hold on yeah maybe
we'll just wait on this see where it
goes and then you fast forward a little
bit more all the way to 2009 and I
talked a few other VCS and and I just
went through kind of an introspective
process because you know like I said in
the talk one of the really fun things
about this was the idea that that people
were saying thank you that that people
were that my great-grandkids could use
this that people kids all over the world
could use this really for all of time
that even if I got hit by a bus these
things could keep teaching and so sorry
I went through the thought experiment of
well what's a homerun in either
situation a homerun in the for-profit
world which isn't
bad thing I mean it's by no means
certain is Wow you know you become this
major player you IPO or you get acquired
or and and I think the the you know I
would feel pretty good about that I
would have created a big business I'm
sure that would have reached many people
I would have become rich which wouldn't
have been bad but but then when you
think about the the home run on a
not-for-profit side it was even a little
more exciting that there's kind of this
opportunity here maybe to start an
institution to start something that
could last maybe hundreds of years I
mean this is what I told my wife is it
you know there are no for-profit
entities that lasts more than you know
very few lasts more than a century but
there are not profit entities that do
and you know not not to put Khan Academy
in the same league as these
organizations but you know what I rather
start a GE or what I rather start a
Stanford and and when I thought about it
that way I was like you know it kind of
be more exciting to start at the ladder
so that's that's the not profit I'm not
and it's interesting your background
it's interesting you bring up Stanford
even your own CV MIT and then to Harvard
you are talking about real traditional
institutions here and what you're doing
in many ways can be viewed as very
untraditional how you're educating
people is there a negative side of this
if you've gotten some pushback whether
it's from the traditional education
community or anyone else in the
community you know right now and then
luckily and I expected a lot more
pushback especially when we go into
schools and all but well the fun thing
is that the core thing what we're doing
we kind of we're going straight to the
student straight to the parent so we
don't have to get buy-in from a lot but
even in the schools where we're dealing
with the schools that have wanted to do
it we're not forcing anybody to do
anything and I think the only resistance
we get is sometimes when people see you
know just kind of it on the surface and
they say oh wait lectures on video
they're going into classrooms we this is
here to replace teachers or this is
somehow going to you know mechanize the
classroom but I think when people well
we're saying those the exact opposite
these videos and the software they're
actually about to kind of Ryu Minh eyes
the classroom instead of having a
teacher up here giving a lecture and
students down there
and passively listening we're offloading
all that with the technology and now
class time becomes interactive we can
tutor each other the teachers going to
walk by every moment of their time is
going to be mentoring each other there's
data there's analytics so that any
intervention that the teacher does is
very productive so the teachers who have
experienced it they've told us this is
why they became teachers in the first
place so yeah I think the only
resistance is just the the knee-jerk
reaction but when they actually see we
were doing we're actually all about
empowering teachers do you think there
would will be some resistance even more
so as Khan Academy gets more well known
right now it's well known but it's gonna
get to that next level where people
especially now the economic climate in
this country where there's so many
budget cuts there's so much bad blood
going back and forth do you expect some
resistance because I'm sure there will
be at some point around the corner yeah
you know and we have to be careful there
because obviously education is very
politically charged a thing and we're
trying our best to stay out of the the
arguments we think regardless of what
where everything else settles we'll we
can be relevant but you know III don't
want to I hope maybe it will develop I'm
not you know but we haven't seen it in a
strong way just yet okay in terms of the
subject matter now you're doing all
these videos about yourself I'm a TV guy
I get a sore throat by talking a lot so
so when you plan on expanding are you
just gonna start bringing in other
experts in various subjects so so you
know based on what our focus is in the
in the short term we don't view that as
a gating factor I you know I'm keep
making videos this is fun for me because
I get to there's some stuff I know and
there's some stuff I get to learn and I
get to keep teaching it and all the rest
and you know even just one guy can do K
through calculus plus chemistry biology
and physics in the course of about three
man years so it is this very scalable
thing but with that said we are starting
to look for other potential lecturers
and I'll even say this audience we're
actually we're translating into 10
languages Hindi Bengali we're already
we've already started on and we want to
do other languages and so there's
there's an option you want to help redo
the videos of those language or even
teaching those languages you know one
thing that we're missing is basic
literacy videos but in like the context
of the developing world that's super
important so yet we are looking to bring
other people in the fold the one thing
we're not looking to do is we don't want
to be this crowd-sourced hundreds
thousands of teachers where you know the
student watches one video from one
teacher and then another video from
another teacher and it's different
quality because that's a very first hole
that's already exists I mean YouTube is
that to some degree there's other sites
that do that and we think that our niche
is really a
a bond with with the teacher I mean it's
crazy because it's technology but we
think we can actually form a bond with
the students and so people once they
watch 10 20 30 videos from the same
teacher they're willing to invest their
time and their emotional energy into it
you can obviously sell and teach this
product amazingly because it's your
product and you have a dynamic
personality and obviously very
intelligent how do you bring the next
person in there to do the story yeah
it's an open question we're we're kind
of doing there's a guy who like American
Idol casting we like teaching Idol we
that's the way there's a couple of
people who there's there's some guys who
are video log bloggers who are pretty
hilarious and intellectual and stuff and
they they want to try it out so we'll
see how they do and there's a guy on you
from MIT who's a computer science he's
been teaching computer science I think
he's got a lot of potential but we're
not in a rush to find these teachers we
want to take our time and find people
who really resonate with students your
biggest fear moving forward obviously
there's been a lot of success now but is
there something in the back of your mind
that you're you're curious about that
maybe a little fearful about as you move
forward with this yeah I think that well
you know I think any any organization at
our stage you don't you don't want to be
a flash in the pan you don't want I mean
I told you the ambition is to be
something that lasts 100 years it'll be
sad if we don't last three years right
so so our main thing is let's just make
sure that we are continuing to drive
value that we don't get caught up in
these other things that I don't make my
the focus of me just going on TV and
talking about education reform and
becoming a policy person or something
like that so I think where we are right
now we're in this kind of inflection
point I think our main goal is to always
just you know put the blinders on stay
focused on on really what got us to this
point which is really the end student
and making sure that we continue to add
value for that that student and then the
people who want to empower them their
parents and their teachers in the Bay
Area here a lot of us familiar with with
school districts that aren't as
successful whether it's an East Oakland
or News Palo Alto are you try to target
specific types of areas demographically
perhaps yeah and we are focused mainly
on the bay area we're looking all over
the the country and oh actually the
world we're going a few international
schools but what we're looking to do Los
Altos is obviously not a community in
need so but what was really good about
Los Altos although two of the great two
of the the seventh grade classes we do
directory
slower tracked kids and they've actually
been doing tremendous it's actually they
they've shown even more profound results
so you know even Los Altos isn't all
uniformly fluent and well-heeled
but what we're looking to do is other
use cases less well-heeled neighborhoods
charter schools private schools public
schools all of the above but the one
theme that we do want and all these
schools is that there's buy-in that it's
not just the mayor or the superintendent
who's forcing it down that the mayor the
superintendent the principal's the
teachers and the parents all really
really really want this because well you
know about the flash of the pan I think
our biggest risk is you know some school
kind of halfway implements it and then
it's a disaster and then you know
everyone points at that it says look it
doesn't work and I think that you know
that that would be a disaster not just
for us but I think for the whole idea
behind it which I think has a lot of
power so our our goal over the next 10
to 15 school districts is just to make
sure that make sure that it they're
unambiguous successes like Los Altos
what about you for the actual content of
it I mean like any teacher and you are a
teacher you have to stay fresh and
current and even continue to learn about
your own topics how do you do that is
that part of your day oh yeah no it's
yeah you know it's there's some stuff
that I know you know by virtue of my
background but there's some stuff like
organic chemistry right yeah I took it
and I did all right in the class but I
took it in college but a lot of people
are asking for organic chemistry it's
like one of these core classes every
pre-med and a lot of science majors take
this and there was actually no organic
chemistry videos along the way even
they're not even bad ones out there and
hey and and so I said I need to learn
organic chemistry and but the one thing
that I emphasizes I don't want to teach
something unless I'm excited about it I
mean it's a we've all experienced a
teacher at the stand at the front of the
classroom who's like the next step in
the process is that you're like if he
doesn't give a damn why should I
and so I won't do a video on this I'm
excited about it and the first day of
studying organic chemistry I was not
that excited about it but but actually
once I immersed myself and really
started thinking about it and really
started drawing the intuition start to
get exciting so I kind of immerse myself
in subjects that I don't know I'll call
my buddies that I think might be able to
connect some dots for me and then once I
feel like I have a holistic picture then
I'll just start recording and you know I
forced a smile
my face and and I and I do it but uh
hopefully shows up in the videos well
like so many people here we stopped in
note Khosla here last night and talking
about just taking a risk going against
the grain going against the analysts
that tell you one thing
you obviously are doing that what's the
spirit what was the I don't know about
push back but when you tell your Indian
parents so I'm anything the hedge fund
and my MIT and Harvard education I'm
gonna do this thing on YouTube a thing
what are you doing oh yeah no I mean
it's funny cuz when I my wife is a she's
finishing up her fellowship at Stanford
right now but when I first told people
that especially the desi parties that I
had oh what do you do oh you know I make
videos on YouTube and and I've actually
heard this they wouldn't they hear I'm
I've heard them but at least his wife's
as a doctor yes so interesting though
yeah thank God my wife's a doctor but
it's uh although you know a resident you
know it wasn't she wasn't making the but
anyway it's a the day the day the day
after I I mean my mother is very
supportive of it now but the day after I
officially had quit and I actually did
not consult my mother not like a good
this he's son but my mother called my
wife and my mother-in-law said what how
did you let him do this you know
everyone's really pumped about it now as
you look around in this room now is
there something that a message that you
would want to kind of put to give to
people here as you see what what you're
doing and moving forward yeah I mean
there's a couple of minute whether
there's a broader message about
entrepreneurship and I think that's you
know I I have a kind of a singular story
I think there's multiple ways obviously
to kind of start something but you know
my story is you can tell it was just me
trying to reach a need and it was
exciting for me when just a handful of
my cousin's were obviously benefiting
from it and that was enough I was happy
with just that small success it was
worth my time to build it then and I
think the lesson is you know whatever
you do hopefully there's some small
subset of people who find it
life-changing for them maybe or in some
way very compelling
and and then if you have that then it
makes it worthwhile for you to do it and
then and then you kind of don't care how
long I mean there's a possibility that
in 2004 I said I'm gonna start this
online video platform and I'm gonna get
venture funding and all of that and I
maybe would have written a business plan
worked at it for six months and if I
didn't get traction I would have given
up and because I had I kind of was happy
with the small successes I was able to
pursue it for for five years before I
quit my job and then even I was pumped
about pursuing it afterward so it's one
of these things where I was kind of this
one of this unkillable ventures and
that's you know I think that's one of
those things that you know make venture
succeed there's a lot of things a lot of
ideas that people have and the ideas
kind of go up and it Pitters out and
then it dies and then eight years later
you see it actually becomes very
successful I so I think there's
something is said about maybe designing
something so it's it has a staying power
before the call from Bill Gates before
all the clicks when it was just with
your family what kept you motivated by
doing this because yes you quit a job a
good salary job yeah
well at that point I did not quit so I
am I'm a practical person there but but
it was worth my time to do it you know I
was still spending probably 50 15 hours
a week with a day job doing this for my
cousin's but what was that leap of faith
moment was there a point when he finally
looked and said you know what I can do
this I want to do this what was that
leap of faith moment moment well that
became pretty clear in in you know
2007-2008 when other people were
watching it and my cousin's were you
know Nadia not to show off but she ended
up taking calculus her freshman year in
high school and we went from being you
know most so when you see that with just
one student you're like this this could
be transformational and so that by
itself made it worthwhile you start
getting the letters from students and
then really I had to wait until 2009
because you know the success of the site
you know balanced off with our own
financial risk is what that was the
point where it just became hard for me
to focus on anything else so we talked
about these cousins now where are they
and are they kind of kind of your role
models here of yeah so I tell Nadia on a
regular basis you better be successful
because this uh there's a lot riding on
this but uh she's uh she's she's now at
Sarah Lawrence and and some of you they
see parents might cringe but she's a
writing major
but she's also premed really and when I
say she's a she's a writing major by
choice because she you know she's
actually a math rock stars and pre-med
by heritage I'm pre-med by her as we
wrap it up here the next phone call from
Bill Gates or whoever it is when they
ask you how you're doing have you gotten
better in these last few years because I
would imagine you have with your
tutorial do you look back on those first
two tours II like oh gosh oh yeah you
know I mean some of the older ones like
my cousins they're not gonna pay me like
I literally answer a telemarketer call
in one of those early videos I don't I
don't I don't edit it out it's just like
no I don't want DISH Network's and I
hang up and and you can edit that out I
don't wanna get but uh yeah I mean now I
mean you know Bill Gates is watching
these videos I feel like maybe it should
be a little nicer a little bit more
thought-out
but but I think one of the things that
captured people's imagination early on
is it it does feel personal it does feel
like there's just a sky recording it
doesn't feel like this publishing
company is doing these computer graphics
and doing all of these and you know the
next step in photosynthesis is when the
might occur
this feels like this very organic thing
and and so I think we want to make it
more nicer easier to watch more polished
but we don't want to make it too
polished I guess yeah and that's a very
good point there's that fine line now
bringing in the TV cameras the earpiece
is the makeup so forth are you flirting
with that line yet or is it still code I
say or we always want to be organic a
guy at is that is kind of this screen
capture board Explorer gal explaining
the concepts in real time not with a
script you know we might experiment with
other things for other form you know
maybe history or literature but for the
most part is gonna be this the same
thing okay so pleasure to spend some
time with you this afternoon I think I
speak for the entire room good luck
continued success Oh
you